leaders of the world's largest
intergovernmental organization are
attending What's called the South Summit
it's 60 years since the g77 was formed
within the United Nations framework 77
developing countries then demanding a
new international economic order to give
them effective control over their own
natural
resources today it's expanded to 134
members the organization's goal is to
allow emerging countries from the So-Cal
Global South to join forces to promote
their economic interests and strengthen
their joint negotiating power on
economic issues what is common is that
there's a recognition that the power in
the International System is skewed in
favor of the north both in terms of
capital as well as Financial system and
it's something that's recognized by
everybody and I think there's a desire
to increase agency as well as bargaining
Power by the collective Global south or
conceptual Global South uh against of
course the Global North uh not exactly
in antagonistic way but to uh level the
playing field that is going to be just
and fair China has been providing
consistent political and economic
support to the g77 since 1994 but is not
a member it is an opportunity for Uganda
this year's Summit theme chosen by the
host Uganda is to reduce the widening
gap between rich and poor Nations so the
notion which is around the theme which
we develop is to to ensure first and
foremost that the least developed are
assisted in the part in the journey and
path of growth by the more developed but
more importantly that it is recognized
that the group will have achieved if the
least develop are also
lifted another major goal here promoting
respect for National sovereignty while
addressing financial needs the g76 7 is
viewed by some as a counter to the G7
that's the organization that represents
the world's most developed economies
while the countries here may not be the
wealthiest in terms of GDP together they
have the most resources a fact that
gives them great power when they come
Together dorsa jaari Al jazer
kalala make sure to subscribe to our
channel to get the latest news from Al
jaaz